- [Narrator] Anyone who
drives a car or trucks goods
across the country has
been dealing with gas
and diesel prices going up
and down throughout the year.
Those price jumps were largely a reaction
to Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and Western allies
subsequent sanctions on Moscow.
Now more price uncertainty's on the way.
That's because a European Union
ban on Russian oil imports
kicks in on December 5th.
Alongside that, the Group of Seven
and some other countries have signed up
to a US pushed price cap on
crude sales of $60 per barrel.
Both moves are intended to
dent a key revenue stream
for Russia while keeping
global oil supplies flowing.
What could that mean
for prices at the pump?
Gas and diesel prices are higher
on average than a year ago,
but have been trending
down in recent weeks.
This could change if
Russia followed through
of its threat to stop exporting oil
in response to the price cap.
(Vladimir Putin speaking Russian)
The Kremlin said it won't
accept the price cap
and that it was assessing the
situation, but the cap of $60
is above the current trading
price of Russian Crude.
So supply cutoff may not
be in Russian President,
Vladimir Putin's, best interests.
The global diesel market,
though, may be more sensitive
to market effects that
play out from the cap.
Stores of the fuel are low in the US,
particularly on the east coast,
which is already competing
with Europe for diesel.
A problem that could become more acute
with any loss of Russian supplies.
Europe has long relied on Russian refiners
for the fuel favored in
sectors like agriculture
and trucking.
If Russia holds back exports
or if European refiners
can't find replacements for Russian oil,
the global market price
for the fuel could rise.
And if diesel becomes more expensive,
the cost of transporting
goods or growing produce
could be passed onto consumers.
Existing sanctions have
so far had limited impact
on Russian oil production.
Nonetheless, the US and
some European countries
are preparing for any
possible supply drops.
Refiners, gas stations
and other buyers got ahead
of any supply shortfalls,
importing more diesel from Saudi Arabia,
the United Arab Emirates and India.
US refiners are currently
well stocked with crude,
so any impact on American consumers
wouldn't be felt for some
time, according to one analyst.
Treasury secretary, Janet
Yellen, said recently
that the US could draw
further from the country's
strategic petroleum reserve
if Russia cuts off its supplies
and raises global prices.
Any immediate major
fallout from the embargo
and the price cap appears unlikely
according to some analysts.
And the average cost of
fuel in the US has fallen
more than 30% from record
highs in the summer
and experts say this
downward trend will continue.
This means there's a chance
Americans will be paying
less at the pump as they
travel home for Christmas
than they did last year,
which was around $3.85.
The lower prices could
be short lived though,
they tend to rise on a seasonal basis
starting in mid-February
according to Gas Buddy.
China relaxing its zero
Covid policy could also cause
a price spike, as could any number
of unforeseen geopolitical tensions.
The uncertainty in the oil
market is far from over.